now the U.S has approved to the sale of
birth control pill without needing a
prescription for the first time the oral
contraceptive called the opal has been
available since the 1970s but only to
those who first see a doctor there will
now be no age restriction once
non-prescription sales begin next year
medical groups have been campaigning for
easier access to contraceptives with
greater urgency ever since the U.S
Supreme Court struck down the right to
an abortion last year
well let's bring in Rachel rabouche she
is the dean at Temple University's
Beasley law school and is also a leading
scholar of reproductive health law she
is in Philadelphia from where she joins
us Rachel Opel I believe was first
approved for a prescription use back in
1973 that means it's been used by women
for half a century I know hormone pills
are already the most commonly prescribed
form of contraception in the U.S just
how much of a difference does this make
it makes a huge difference because often
people say that the reason they are not
using pills they're not using oral
contraceptives is because of the travel
to get to a clinic needing to have a
primary care provider having someone
who's going to prescribe it to you and
being able to walk into a Walgreens or
CVS and buy it like you would buy a
vitamin or any other over-the-counter
drug I think will really ease access I
think the big question is how much is it
going to cost
well I was going to ask you about that
because accessibility is really also
determined by price and I believe if
it's not a prescription it also isn't
usually covered by insurance is that a
worry
that's right so the Affordable Care Act
in the United States covers
prescriptions and contraceptives that
are prescribed to people but I think the
Biden Administration has already said
that it's looking to require states to
include these over-the-counter
contraceptives in their insurance plans
and the company itself has pledged to
try to make the drug as accessible and
affordable as possible so I think
affordability is on top of people's
minds well birth control is already
available over the counter and more than
a hundred other countries around the
world how does the US compare globally
when we talk about women's reproductive
rights now
you know I think the U.S is increasingly
an outlier I think the clear Trend
globally has been to allow abortion and
now the United States has a third of it
the country that bans all abortion from
the earliest moments of pregnancy as you
say many countries allow contraceptives
over the counter really in a way to try
to to reduce the unintended pregnancies
uh that are that make up 50 of the
pregnancies in the United States I think
this is a really important move and what
is a crucial moment in the U.S one that
really threatens uh women's reproductive
Health Rachel so you say this is a
really crucial moment in the U.S this in
particular was a decision by the FDA
right the Food and Drug Administration a
regulatory body could an FDA decision on
say the abortion pill perhaps get past
some of the legal battles we're seeing
emerge
the FDA is certainly embroiled in those
legal battles over the abortion pill
Texas Court striking down essentially
suspending the FDA approval of
medication abortion methopristone that
was approved over 20 years ago the fifth
circuit doing the same and now it's you
know that we're back in court and
waiting we're going to probably see the
case go before the United States Supreme
Court so I think the FDA has been at the
center of these com conversations and it
will be interesting to see if the FDA is
sued uh if this decision is challenged
like its decisions around medication
abortion have been challenged Rachel it
sounds like you think that this is
obviously a step in the right direction
do you think that that might perhaps
provide some momentum further in that
direction
[Music]
potentially and I I really think it's a
step in the right direction in a country
that you know where there are states
that ban abortion making contraceptives
as as
available as possible I think really
meet the demand for people who might
otherwise have unintended pregnancies
and not really have options uh Beyond
giving birth or adoption or ordering
pills online to self-manage their own
abortions so I think the more available
contraceptives are in a regime that's
restrictive on abortion rights that's a
good thing
Rachel rebuchet the dean at Temple
University's Beasley law school and also
a leading scholar of reproductive health
law thank you for joining us and sharing
your expertise with us here on altazira
Rachel
thank you so much